and joining me now is chris swecker a
former assistant director of the fbi
uh chris um
we're hearing dribs and drabs uh about
this uh shooter who's now dead uh
pictures reportedly on instagram that
have been deleted
of his weapons and these messages uh
reportedly to uh women uh in his life
what's your initial assessment of all
this
yeah again laura an unspeakable cowardly
act i have grandchildren wanting to turn
nine today i can't imagine what these
parents are having to deal with with
their hearts ripped out
like every mass shooter especially the
young ones this one was flashing red it
appears
which is no surprise i mean they they
always they seem to always communicate
threats they seem to articulate what
they're thinking their state of mind the
people around them can't help but notice
that we don't know whether anybody
reported this and whether any any law
enforcement officer ever had any contact
with him over this
but i do school security assessments
quite often
and i advocate always for an armed
security guard at every school
especially the elementary schools where
the little ones can't run hide fight you
can't do that with with the little ones
they don't have the you know the acumen
and the wherewithal to do that
so there there's a lot to to to take in
here laura
well there's a lot can be be done as
andrew pollock who lost his daughter
meadow at the parkland
school shooting there's a lot that can
be done even short of having an armed
security officer
at the front of every
entrance or exit i mean whether it's
bulletproof glass whether it's intercom
only ringing someone who's previously
cleared
there there are barriers to entry that
can be put up but they're inconvenient
and it's a it's an it's a it's a
wonderful community uvalde it's an
incredible place
so
they just go by the wayside that's human
nature until a tragedy occurs
security is a tough field because you
don't get any attention you don't get
any resources
unless something bad happens it's hard
to make that case when something
catastrophic has not happened but you're
right one of the one of the most
important things you can do is control
access especially after school has
started and in this case there are there
ought to be one access point for for
especially for an elementary school
which is fairly small
and a threat assessment team inside the
school if someone is flashing red or
somebody is exhibiting behaviors there
needs to be a team that gets together
and assesses what's going on and goes to
gets law enforcement involved
chris i'm actually surprised we don't
know more about this shooter yet with
the world that we have and the how fast
information flies that there aren't more
people who actually knew him well who've
already spoken out are you a little bit
surprised about that
is that a profile perhaps
i i am and i sense that a lot is being
withheld right now for for example i
think there was a chase involved
the accident tips me off the fact that
he was in some you know he had just uh
shot his grandmother that the officers
were on the scene so quickly i hear
about uh independent school district
officers that were already there very
there very quickly
i sense that there might have been a a
chase
involved the father said that actually
in a quote
all right well chris we're going to stay
on this thank you very much for joining
us tonight hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else